sorry goose but it's time to buzz the
tower
all right that seems uh that seems super
bad
yeah as maverick's defense attorney i've
got to say he needs to at this point
not say anything to anyone about what
just happened lock himself into a room
and hope for the best we're gonna have a
good time
always there's a new top gun which
reminded me they broke a whole bunch of
laws in the original movie but to talk
about all the military law that maverick
and goose broke i needed some help so i
called in some air support my friend the
lawyer and former major in the marines
the scowl owl to my legal eagle spencer
spencer thanks for coming happy to be
here devon so apparently everyone on the
internet is an expert in military law
but what makes you qualified to talk
about all of the broken laws in top gun
i was a judge advocate in the marine
corps where i prosecuted people
including on marine corps air base
miramar which is where top gun was
actually set i was also an artillery
officer and a joint terminal attack
controller i did that in iraq where i
was calling in airstrikes and what that
means is i was working with pilots to my
left to my right and above me and i saw
the good the bad and the ugly and now
i'm a deputy district attorney in the
pacific northwest where i prosecute
major felony crimes all right internet a
real former marine has entered the chat
so beware devin i've got the need the
need for speed no the need to put some
pilots in jail all right let's dig in
you know
it's a minor detail but there's no
actual such thing as a mig-28 really
there's no mig-28 that sounds like a
real thing we
happen to see a mig-28 do a 4g negative
dive no it's there's actually a mig-29
but i think they just subtracted one for
this film for some reason the mate 28 oh
okay so what are the planes that are
standing in for
well whatever bad guy is uh
uh antagonizing the americans here mate
28. those are actually f5s that have
been painted black and they add that
little red star on the tail
aha interesting you know fun fact they
actually never identify who the enemy or
the opposition is in this entire movie
and we know for a fact that it's the
same one at the beginning and at the end
it's just
the opposite side the bad side
this is ghostwriter117 this bogey's all
over me he's got missile lock on me do i
permission to fire do not
so this is a this is an odd situation
it's not unusual for there to be tension
between militaries where the governments
aren't exactly friendly to each other i
mean we have to understand this film as
we are not at war with this other
country there's obvi this is the cold
war there are tensions
but we're not actually in a shooting war
the problem is the second that anyone
shoots the other person gets to shoot
back in the law of war self-defense is
always available to a party so the pilot
here is actually making the right choice
we're not going to start the war
and whoever that commander is
is saying you don't get to shoot until
you're fired upon because the u.s
doesn't want to start this firing war
yeah and anyone who's in the the
military who's going to be going into
either direct combat operations or
close to combat operations they're going
to be advised on all sorts of rules of
engagement what they're allowed to do
what kind of permission they have to get
to engage but one thing that every
single soldier marine sailor is taught
before going on a deployment is
you are allowed to act in self-defense
you just have to use your judgment and
be real careful before you start a
shooting war with someone that we're not
in a shooting war with
is this your idea of fun man
greetings
watch the birdie
okay now uh i'm just a humble country
lawyer here but it seems to me that if
an f14 was inverted on top of an f5 that
the tail wings would absolutely smack
each other and
eve yeah i mean even if they weren't
somehow that seems like such an
inherently dangerous thing that uh if i
was the commanding officer of these
pilots uh i would not want them to go
inverted because if they
crashed they would have started a
complete international incident that
seems like a really bad idea
i mean this is the kind of behavior
which is so hollywood but
they're committing a crime right now
oddly enough they're committing a crime
as cool as it is the crime is improperly
hazarding an aircraft and the reality of
that crime is that in time of war you
could get the death penalty for that yes
sir
but admittedly looks cool as hell
well and that's rule number one rule
number one in the military is look cool
trouble come on man we're getting low on
gas let's land this sucker
okay so
is the
instruction to land is that an order did
he disobey an order to go up and and
help a fellow pilot also i don't know
how you help another pilot uh from
another plane but that's a separate
issue you know
he's committing at least two different
crimes uh right now he's willfully
disobeying an order from a superior
commissioned officer the land that plane
that's an order he was instructed to
land he's got to land
he's also improperly hazarding an
aircraft
the fuel is low and he's going off to do
something uh apparently give moral
support yeah moral support i don't know
if he's planning on ejecting from his
plane into the other plane to give maybe
a back rub and like help out his buddy
but either way it's not looking good so
you're saying it's it's not standard
operating procedure to fly a plane
without fuel to try and give moral
support to a pilot who uh seems to
be under the weather for some reason you
know that's generally frowned upon yeah
okay
okay so i know this one uh tom cruise is
driving a motorcycle very fast in
california with no helmet on whatsoever
that is a violation of california's
vehicular code uh might be petty but
it's a 250 fine uh and or a year of
probation oh yeah yeah and uh i mean
these pilots are probably right into the
tower saying who the hell is this
random guy
driving his motorcycle along the flight
line shaking his fist at us i'd get an
investigation at least
and also as someone who rides a
motorcycle i can't fathom writing
without a helmet i know there are some
states that you can ride a motorcycle
without a helmet
first of all uh it's dangerous enough
without a helmet like you should wear a
helmet because the injuries of people
that don't wear a helmet are
gruesome and grotesque but also if
you're riding really fast there's so
much wind your aviator sunglasses don't
do that much so if you value your life
please wear a helmet while you ride a
motorcycle uh whether it's in california
or anywhere else please
i'm charlotte blackwood i'm maverick
maverick
does mother not like you or something
no it's my call sign
okay
that is so cringe
that is so so cringe you just don't do
that
that is the biggest dork move in the
world what what's going on here he's
introducing himself by his call sign to
us
i mean that is so cringe but it's it's
also unrealistic and the reason it's
unrealistic is because no one no one has
a cool call sign like that
maverick iceman
you don't get call signs like that every
call sign is going to be something
unique and weird about you or something
that you did which is borderline
embarrassing humiliating
if you were to go into a place and say i
want my call sign to be maverick you
would probably be hazed to the point of
death
don't do this
don't do this but they they had a
connection
so i i have no doubt in maverick's mind
that he has a special connection with
this lady
and that this was an invitation with her
eyes
for him to come join her in the ladies
room let me put it this way he's
probably breaking at least three laws
here let's assume for a second that this
poor woman had no intention of inviting
maverick into the ladies room i think
that's probably safe to say yeah so
he's basically committing a couple
different crimes one conduct on becoming
an officer or gentleman this is so basic
it that is literally the text of the
statute conduct unbecoming an officer or
gentleman it all it requires to show is
that he's doing something indecent
immoral something wrong
um it's also probably prejudicial to
good order and discipline or has a
tendency to discredit the armed forces
which is a violation of article 134 of
the informed code of military justice
yeah well it sounds bad when you put it
that way i mean he's in uniform on base
this kind of behavior is really
dangerous for him she has a phd in
astrophysics and she's also a civilian
contractor so you do not salute her
but you better listen to her because the
pentagon listens to her about your
proficiency it's all yours charlie thank
you
hello
okay so
is it at all realistic that there would
be a civilian who
uh is some sort of uh contractor that
would be providing some instruction to
the the pilots at top gun i don't think
it's unusual or i don't think it's so
unusual that it's unrealistic we have
civilian contractors everywhere in the
military doing a wide variety of things
and especially people who have specific
training and experience like having a
phd in astrophysics i'm sure that they
could be useful to some extent probably
not talking about tactics but talking
about
uh the aerodynamics of the aircraft
things like that
i'm not sure that uh astrophysics would
help with aerodynamics i think
was it like astrophysics phd in
astrophysics they said yeah they said
astrophysics so unless they're they're
charting with the stars uh i'm not sure
her uh her phd is going to help that
much i guess we're assuming that she has
a bunch of other experience in the
private sector that led her to to this
expertise well you know it is possible i
suppose that top gun 2 is actually going
to be in space yes
yes
in space
welcome to the
danger zone that's classified it's what
it's classified
i could tell you but then i'd have to
kill you lieutenant i have top secret
clearance
the pentagon sees to it that i know more
than you
yeah okay so
uh i i've never been in the military but
i do have a lot of friends who have uh
ts sci clearance
and
she might have that kind of clearance
but
none of them necessarily have tssci
right like
i don't think all of those pilots are
necessarily going to have the clearance
to be able to hear what he just said he
can't tell people without that
particular clearance
i mean yeah i would assume every single
officer has secret clearance at least
okay but getting tssci is actually
somewhat more unusual costs a lot of
money
and actually has quite a bit of value on
the private sector once you leave the
military yes i have heard that i will
say this for all of you who are watching
if you have a little bit of classified
information that you're not allowed to
tell anyone and a civilian just tells
you oh it's okay i have security
clearances here
do not
do not give them that classified
information uh it's gonna be bad day for
you if that person does not in fact have
that security clearance no no man this
is not a good idea sorry goose but it's
time to buzz the tower
god damn son of a [ __ ]
all right that seems uh that seems super
bad
yeah as maverick's defense attorney i've
got to say he needs to at this point
not say anything to anyone about what
just happened lock himself into a room
and hope for the best so yeah what did
he just do there
a number of crimes i mean honestly this
is one of those cases where he could get
racked up on maybe five different counts
uh he certainly willfully disobeyed uh
the order of a superior commissioned
officer there's another article at the
ucmj about drunken or reckless operation
of an aircraft uh there's another one
reckless endangerment there's another
conduct on becoming an officer and a
gentleman
improperly hazarding an aircraft some of
those could carry the death penalty the
reality is some of those would be harder
to prove some would be easier the one
that he absolutely just did
is disobeying that order and that's a
bad bad thing for him yeah it seems like
in the military you kind of have to
follow orders we follow orders or people
die you know it's it's strongly
suggested and unfortunately in the real
world not only would he get grounded he
would probably lose his wings entirely
and spend the rest of his time on his
contract like filling sandbags or doing
something very menial in an office
sounds about right that's because every
time you go up in the air you're unsafe
i don't like you because you're
dangerous that's right
nice
man
i am dangerous
that's what we call an admission uh and
unfortunately for him it is absolutely
true and goes back to some of the
reckless things that he's been doing
this entire time again as maverick's
defense attorney i strongly advise him
to remain silent when it comes to this
kind of stuff okay so so that reminds me
of a certain fan theory about top gun
which is that top gun is really a love
story between two characters not
tom cruise and kelly mcgillis but rather
uh tom cruise's character and val
kilmer's character iceman
if let's say
maverick and iceman
were not married but then decided to
have a relationship with each other
would that violate any rules of the ucmj
so what it would probably violate would
be a regulation that says people who are
on the same command cannot have intimate
relationships um now if they because
they're both at the top gun school
you're not allowed to have an intimate
relationship just because of the way
that that could impact the school the
command etc
however once they're outside of top gun
as long as they're not in the same unit
they can have the most wonderful
relationship that they could possibly
want and i wish them the best
[Music]
[Applause]
i could be my wingman any time you know
funny story i actually was a military
prosecutor assigned to what is now
marine corps air station miramar uh and
i watched at least one pilot get
prosecuted one pilot got entirely
dismissed from the marine corps he was a
test pilot for an f-35 and it was for
adultery he he got kicked out for
adultery so i mean that's not a crime uh
for civilians that's a crime for uh
service members it absolutely is and
it is actually a frighteningly common
crime for service members now it's not
it's not enough that you had an affair
when you're married or you had an affair
with someone who is married
there has to be something additional to
it it has to be either prejudicial to
good or indisciplined or have a tendency
to discredit the armed forces but in
adultery cases
they're not that hard to show
yeah i mean so so why would adultery be
something that the military cares about
well for one there are a lot of
moralistic prigs who are in the military
but the other part of it is you really
can't have people especially in the same
chain of command or on the same base who
are themselves married and having
affairs with other people on the base so
for example let's say that you're a
captain like maverick you're single but
you decide to have an affair with
someone who's married on the base and
that person is a civilian but married to
another officer for example
that can cause real tensions inside of
the base inside of the command and that
is prejudicial to good order and
discipline because you're introducing so
much possibility for
anger recrimination
it's just something you want to avoid
entirely sir
i had commander heather lee in my sights
he saw me move in for the kill he then
proceeded
below the hard deck
we weren't below 10 000 for more than a
few seconds
i had the shot
there was no danger so i took it so
here's the problem with this what he did
by going underneath the hard deck was a
violation of the regulations but also
let's talk about what the hard deck
really meant in this context yeah what
does that mean the hard deck simulates
the ground so when he says that he went
beneath the hard deck only for a few
seconds that's like saying in your
aircraft you went beneath the ground for
a couple seconds
that hard deck is there for everyone's
safety so that you have lots of buffer
room in a training environment
and for him to just be underneath it for
a couple seconds well you know i'm sure
the aircraft will be fine underneath the
desert of california for a couple
seconds it's an aircraft and a submarine
that's how good we are
we're getting there guys the
communication chip ss layton has become
disabled and has wandered into foreign
territory a rescue operation is to begin
within the hour your mission is to give
air support to that rescue so this is
kind of a complicated setup um we're
obviously tensions are high and there's
the possibility of war or some sort of
hostile act here
where we actually are going to see
combat
now we have to assume that what that
means
in the film
is that this ship has drifted into what
are called territorial waters
territorial waters for any country on
the ocean they extend about 12 miles out
but because the law of the sea there's
an exception to that which is called
innocent passage so what innocent
passage means is if another ship goes
through and all they're doing is going
to port or going through those
territorial waters with innocent motives
then you can't just attack them it's not
an invasion of the country or anything
like that now what they can do of course
is they can
police their territorial waters so
someone comes in for on innocent passage
you can board them you can search them
you can do a variety of things to make
sure that it is in fact innocent passage
so the problem is that while there's
innocent passage in the sea there is no
such thing as innocent passage in the
air
the second that a u.s combat aircraft
goes into the airspace above another
country's territorial waters
that could be very clearly seen as an
act of war oh well that that complicates
things a lot i think yeah
yeah so what you're saying is that the
american planes are entering into a
zone
of danger
a sort of
danger zone
they are in fact going into the danger
zone
danger
all right so we've already talked about
how much of a blatant violation buzzing
the tower is
back in miramar
uh assuming
that they weren't run out on rail
what would happen if they buzzed a tower
again after being reprimanded the first
time nothing good
in fact very very bad things um i think
it's safe to say that at this point
maverick is not just going to be
stripped of his wings but he's probably
going to get dismissed from the service
and also on top of it um
we're at war now the the this
unidentified country has shot down an
american plane
i think by all reasonable accounts that
means that we are at war with this
country seems like a really super bad
time to be showboating absolutely and
the reality is i mean we do find out
slightly later in this film that this
other country is going to decide that
hey it's no big deal but we don't know
that right now everyone on this aircraft
carrier has to assume that we are at war
right now with this country
and yet we're doing a flyby
yeah yeah so yeah that seems that seems
bad
suboptimal
[Applause]
somewhere there is a chief petty officer
in the navy screaming and sobbing into a
pillow
the fact that we are in war right now or
at least we have to assume that we're in
war and the entire deck crew is
abandoning their posts running out to
celebrate these guys when for all we
know there's a there's a bunch of other
migs heading directly for this aircraft
carrier
i mean
these people need to be at their posts
they need to be retro like they need to
be refueling refitting these aircraft
they need to be getting combat air
patrol out there and instead they're all
just having the time of their lives i i
don't even know what to say
i don't even know what to say
yeah it looks like they just won a
college football game yeah i mean they
definitely just scored a touchdown
unfortunately
we may have nukes in the other end zone
all right spencer uh now we need to
tally all the crimes how long is
tom cruise's maverick going to jail
let me put it this way if we are in fact
at war he's probably going to get the
death penalty if we're not actually at
war he's probably gonna get oh let's say
about three to four years in the brig
and a dismissal from the armed forces
and a 250 fee for not wearing a helmet
while riding motorcycle that really is
the knife that twists isn't it
well spencer you can be my wingman
anytime
no devin you can be mine
[Laughter]
you two characters
are going the top gun so the navy is
going to fire maverick or i guess they
might hang him from a yard arm but this
is america so he'll probably just sue to
get his job back and he could really
benefit from my feature-length master
course on nebula classes it's called how
to sue like a lawyer i'd take you
through the legal process step by step
in a fun and entertaining way you know
in case you ever need to sue someone or
you're just curious how that whole thing
works and not only that but i have
another class called copyright for fun
and profit explains everything you ever
wanted to know about copyright and ip
whether you're a creator artist or
student because today's sponsor nebula
classes is a brand new part of nebula
the creator-owned streaming platform
that i'm building with a bunch of my
creator friends every class is insanely
well produced and entertaining we fly
every creator to new york to shoot with
the entire nebula classes team it's a
little bit like masterclass from the
creators that you love i promise you you
will get lost in the rabbit hole of
amazing classes because it's not just my
classes there are classes from thomas
frank on productivity amy nolte on jazz
improv sam from wendover on persuasion
and tons of others we have new classes
dropping every week led by your favorite
creators and experts in their field and
it's not just full-length classes we're
also hosting nebula talks inspirational
short form guest lectures kind of like
ted from the creators that you love and
better yet since classes is part of
nebula you'll also get access to all of
my exclusive and ad-free content that i
usually release early and nebula has
just passed over 500 000 happily paying
customers so if you're one of the few
people that hasn't already signed up now
is your chance to discover the greatest
collection of thought-provoking videos
on the planet and you'll find new things
to discover every day and you can watch
all of this great stuff just about
anywhere with your iphone ipad android
android tv apple tv and roku apps and
best of all if you're already a nebulous
subscriber upgrading to classes is just
an extra five dollars per month and if
you're signing up for the first time the
whole thing is only ten dollars per
month or a hundred dollars per year but
for a limited time if you go to
nebulaclasses.com legaleagle or click on
the link that's on screen right now or
in the description there's a special
discount of 20 off the easiest thing to
do is click on the link that's on screen
right now to access the amazing nebula
classes those funds go directly to the
creators and funds even more amazing
content again just click on the link
that's on screen or in the description
to see why nebula classes rocks and
while you're there click on this other
link for all of my other videos or i'll
see you in court